Olá aqui Dr Machado Dutra médico há mais
de 25 anos e hoje eu vou contar para
vocês uma história que me tocou
profundamente o pequeno Jedi é um
garotinho de apenas dois aninhos cheio
de energia e sempre apuntando suas
travessuras de repente tudo mudou Jedi
começou a se fechar em o mundo só dele
parou de brincar de falar malfer contato
visual com a família era como se uma Néa
tivesse descido entre ele e o resto do
mundo uma névoa de silêncio e distância
os seus pais muito preocupados com essa
mudança tão drástica procuraram vários
especialistas fizeram uma série de exam
de avaliações até que um deles um
simples exame de sangue revelou algo
chocante o nível de metal pesado chumbo
no sangue de jedai estava nas alturas
estava 76 quando o normal seria menos de
3,5 a situação era tão crítica que levou
o jedi direto para a UTI onde começou um
tratamento urgente para desintoxicação
do Chumbo mas como é que isso aconteceu
como que jedai uma criança de apenas 2
anos acabou intoxicado por um metal
pesado tão perigoso a resposta estava
bem na frente dos olhos da família sem
que eles percebessem a casa onde moravam
um lugar antigo em Chicago para onde se
mudaram em 2021 tinha pinturas com
tintas a base de chumbo nas paredes e
portas aquelas paredes descascadas e a
poeira acumulada não eram apenas sinais
do tempo mas partículas de chumbo
esperando para causar problemas a
história do Jedi não acabou depois de
sair da UTI até hoje ele enfrenta
dificuldades de fala e um transtorno
chamado [ __ ] que é essa vontade
incontrolável de comer coisas que não
são comida como Terra areia coisas que
são considerada sujeira então esses
problemas são diretas consequências da
intoxicação pro chumbo e demanda um
cuidado constante isso não é apenas um
caso isolado como vocês vão descobrir
nesse vídeo pessoal 800 milhões de
pessoas no mundo 800 milhões podem estar
com níveis de chumo no sangue ou nos
ossos acima do permitido causando danos
à saúde além disso a contaminação pelo
metal é responsável pela morte 5 milhões
55 milhões e meio de adultos por
problemas cardiovasculares ao ano que
pessoas só pensa em colesterol é uma
muito sério e grave e que ainda temos
poucas fontes de informações aqui no
Brasil o que me preocupa muito é
especialmente a saúde dos pequenos bebês
e crianças menores de 5 anos são
particularmente bastante vulneráveis aos
efeitos nocivos do Chumbo isso porque
esse metal pesado pode danificar o
cérebro deles antes mesmo que ten uma
chance de desenvolvimento completo
Imaginem só o cérebro de uma criança tá
em plena formação e o chumbo pode se
acumular ali causando danos de
irreversíveis não estamos falando apenas
de impactos no cérebro Mas também de
prejuízos neurológicos cognitivos e
físicos que podem acompanhar a pessoa
por toda a vida Isso inclui desde a
nossa capacidade de prestar atenção e
desempenho na escola até comportamentos
agressivos e antissociais que podem até
ser diagnosticados como autismo e para
quem pensa que isso é tudo a exposição
ao chumbo ainda pode estar relacionado a
condições graves como TDH autismo anemia
câncer osteoporose neuropatia periférica
hipertensão arterial e até doenças
cardíacas o chubo tem um jeito bem traço
de agir no organismo Ele é quimicamente
parecido com cálcio e ele rouba o lugar
desse mineral tão importante o cálcio
tem um papel fundamental na sinapse das
nossas células nervosas a conexão entre
os neurônios que permitem que eles se
comuniquem entre si mas o que acontece é
que o chumbo pode enganar o nosso corpo
e tomar o lugar do cálcio e quando isso
acontece os sinais que deveriam ser
transmitidos entre as células nervosas
não conseguem passar de uma célula para
outra e o que que dá isso Qual é o
resultado as células nervosas acabam
morrendo e isso pode levar o
encolhimento do cérebro que é assustador
né o chubo também tem o hábito de se
depositar nos nossos dentes e ossos vai
se acumulando com o tempo isso pode
trazer problemas bem sérios por exemplo
se uma mãe foi exposta ao chumbo Isso
significa que seus ossos contêm esse
metal durante a gravidez o cálcio
presente nos ossos é super importante
pro desenvolvimento do bebê mas se os
ossos da mãe tem chumbo esse metal o
chumbo é que vai passar por o feto em
vez do cálcio necessário então o chumbo
parece ter uma preferência especial
pelos nossos ossos o que pode nos
colocar em risco de desenvolver
problemas cardiovasculares e osteoporose
de forma precoce quando falamos da
exposição ao chumbo muita gente pode não
saber mas os sintomas podem ser bem
variados e afetar várias partes do nosso
corpo entre os sinais físicos podemos
sentir dor e cólicas abdominais
constipação dores de cabeça frequentes
um cansaço que parece que não tem fim
pressão alta e até uma dormência nas
mãos e pés além disso a exposição ao
chumbo pode levar a perda de memória
anemia e até problemas nos rins no lado
comportamental e psicológico a coisa
também fica complicada pode aparecer
agressividade irritabilidade que a gente
não sabe de onde vem problemas para
dormir perda de apetite até uma queda
significativa nas habilidades
desenvolvimento isso é especialmente
preocupante nas crianças obviamente
falando em crianças os efeitos do chubo
nos pequenos são são ainda mais
alarmantes pode ocorrer um q mais baixo
um déficit de desenvolvimento
intelectual dificuldade de aprendizagem
notas baixas na escola problemas de
audição e até atraso de crescimento é a
situação pode ser séria pessoal o chumbo
pode ser encontrado em vários lugares
não só na poeira de tintas antigas ele
também pode estar no ar que respiramos
na água que bebemos nos alimentos que
comemos e até nos solos dos lugares onde
nossas crianças brincam e não para por
aí até a água da torneira pode ser uma
fonte de exposição ao chumbo se a casa
ou local tiver encanamentos antigos
metálicos brinquedos móveis canos velhos
paques infantis até áreas de lazer com
pintur descascando especialmente aquelas
com estruturas metálicas antigas em mau
estado de conservação são todos
potenciais riscos agora escutem isso
pesquisadora de univ cidades federais
Estaduais de São Paulo aqui em São Paulo
fizeram um estudo descobriram algo bem
preocupante eles investigaram se os
níveis de chumbo encontrados em
residências e creches de crianças na
fase
pré-escolar aqui do
Brasil estavam Associados ou não com
elevados níveis de chumbo no sangue o
estudo publicado em
2018 na revista environmental pollution
encontrou uma
associação ficativa entre as duas
variáveis e sabe onde encontraram as
maiores concentrações de chumbo nos
azulejos e equipamentos de playground
infantil sim Aquelas mesmas áreas onde
nossas crianças passam horas brincando e
se divertindo podem estar expondo essas
crianças a níveis preocupantes de chumbo
o mais alarmante é que a exposição ao
chumbo nas creches onde as crianças
passam muitas horas do dia mostrou ser
tão relevante quanto às Exposições
dentro do próprio domicílio e os altos
níveis de chumbo tiveram um impacto
maior em crianças mais novas de 1 a 3
anos Isso é extremamente preocupante
Pessoal vocês Acredito que até o ar que
a gente respira pode estar contaminado
com chumbo um estudo recente em Londres
trouxe à tona uma realidade assustadora
o chumbo que era utilizado na gasolina
antiga mente ainda está no ambiente
persiste no ar da capital britânica isso
mesmo a gasolina com chumbo que
felizmente já foi banida há mais de duas
décadas no Reino Unido e no Brasil
também deixa ainda rastros que afeta o
meio ambiente e a nossa saúde mas não é
só em Londres que isso acontece em
cidades pelo mundo aa como Shangai e até
aqui em São Paulo foram encontrar os
resultados semelhantes você que é do
estado da Bahia deve conhecer a história
da contaminação por chumbo em Santo
Amaro da Purificação perto de Salvador
este é um dos casos mais alarmantes de
dano ambiental e a saúde pública do
Brasil e é uma história que precisa ser
contada e relembrada para que não se
repita por décadas a companhia
brasileira de chumbo conhecida como
cobrac operou nessa região despejando no
ambiente quantidades enormes de resíduos
tóxicos incluindo chumbo e cádmio esse
resíduos contaminaram a atmosfera as
águas e o solo trazendo consequências
devastadoras paraa saúde dos moradores
da capital baiana e região entre os
problemas causados estão a diminuição do
QI problemas renais anemia outros
impactos sérios à saúde Além disso há um
grande número de crianças na região com
problemas de saúde deficiências físicas
e anomalias os registros oficiais também
mostram casos de desnutrição doenças
crônicas e um comprometimento geral da
qualidade de vida tanto dos ex-operários
da cobrac quanto da população em geral
infelizmente muitos dos que trabalharam
na empresa sofreram falecimentos
precoces uma triste realidade que marca
profundamente a comunidade e o mais
angustiante até hoje os moradores de
Sant Amaro espero por justiça a história
de Santo Amaro é um alerta sobre a
importância da Necessidade de vigilância
constante para proteger nossas
comunidades pessoal parece incrível mas
até canela pode ser uma fonte de
exposição ao chumbo um caso que nos faz
abrir os olhos aconteceu recentemente
com saquinhos de compota de maçã com
canela uma marca dessas papinhas que a
gente confia para alimentar as crianças
foi encontrada com nível alarmante de
chumbo mais de 400 crianças foram
intoxicadas nos Estados Unidos a
suspeita é que a canela usada na compota
estava contaminada talvez a até de forma
intencional para aumentar o peso do
produto com isso os lucros é um
verdadeiro alerta para todos nós sobre
como até os alimentos algo tão
fundamental paraa nossa vida podem estar
comprometidos Então na hora de escolher
especiarias como canela açafrão cuminho
e outros temperos especialmente aqueles
em pó é crucial escolher fornecedores de
qualidade de confiança a canela por
exemplo já foi conhecida por ter esse
tipo de problema então é melhor prevenir
do que remediar Ok Vale destacar que
especiarias que venham especialmente do
Norte da Índia e do Paquistão onde
avaliações recentes apontam para um
padrão de
adulteração ou seja podem conter chumbo
fique de olho dessas regiões você sabia
que até os ustensiles de cozinha aquelas
peças de cerâmica lindas que a gente
adora podem representar um risco pra
saúde um exemplo clássico vem do México
um país rico rico em cultura e tradições
mas que enfrentou sérios problemas que
vê da intoxicação por chumbo devido a
seu tradicional artesanato em cerâmica
decorado com tintas à base do Chumbo
pessoal as panelas com revestimento
cerâmico ou as esmaltadas que não são
certificadas podem conter chumbo cdmo na
tinta que durante o cozimento podem ser
liberados nos alimentos aumentando o
risco de contaminação Mas acreditem o
problema não para por aí brinquedos
maquiagens cosméticos tinturas para
cabelo joias bijuterias e até cigarro
podem conter chumbo precisamos estar
atentos muito atentos Especialmente
quando se trata de produtos destinados
às crianças um estudo realizado por
pesquisadores da faculdade de saúde
pública da USP do Instituto de Pesquisa
tecnológica de São Paulo e da
Universidade Federal do ABC desses três
institut prodos juntos identificou altas
concentrações de cádmio e chumbo em
utensilos plásticos coloridos como copos
canecas pratos e tigelas que
supostamente são destinadas ao uso
infantil Então como podemos proteger a
nós mesmos e a nossas famílias
primeiramente Fique atento a objetos do
cotidiano dê preferência para aqueles
com certificação de qualidade e mantenha
as crianças longe de brinquedos que
estão descascando ou de procedência
desconhecida e sobre maquiagens como
batons e delineadores que também podem
estar contaminados por chumbo geralmente
são macas baratas e de procedência
desconhecida muitas vezes adquiridas em
varejistas de comércio geral ou pela
internet a dica aqui é optar por
produtos de marcas reconhecidas e
confiáveis que seguem padrões rigorosos
de qualidade e segurança ao longo dos
anos produtos fabricados na China e
outras partes da Ásia tem enfrentado uma
crise de credibilidade inúmeros
escândalos revelaram problema graves de
má qualidade e falta de controle de
segurança nas manufaturas isso é
preocupante principalmente porque muitos
desses produtos acabam sendo acessíveis
para as camadas mais pobres da população
mais Humildes infelizmente para as
pessoas mais necessitadas optar por
produtos certificados e de qualidade que
geralmente tem um custo mais elevado é
Um Desafio enorme muitas vezes a escolha
é entre comprar algo mais barato mesmo
sem de procedência conhecida ou não
comprar nada como se pode então
priorizar a preocupação com a exposição
ao chumbo Por exemplo quando a principal
preocupação é garantir comida na mesa
essa situação destaca uma realidade dura
a necessidade de uma atuação mais forte
das instituições responsáveis pela
fiscalização de produtos e locais com
potencial de contaminação é essencial
que haja mais esforço para garantir que
todos tenham a acesso a produtos seguros
de forma Independente da sua renda Não é
justo que as pessoas mais simples mais
Humildes mais vulneráveis sejam as mais
expostas a risco de saúde devido à falta
de opções a saúde e a segurança deve ser
uma prioridade para todos de forma
independente do status econômico
compartilhe os vídeos bem a vida de
alguém pode também no
canal AL
Não esqueça de curtir esse vídeo
compartilhar com seus amigos e
familiares com as pessoas que podem
precisar muito dessa informação sua
participação é essencial para
continuarmos abordando temas tão
importantes para nossa saúde muito
obrigado pela sua atenção um grande
abraço um beijo no seu coração e você é
feira